all right it's 10:30 a.m. in San
Francisco I'm by myself in the studio
because Shawn wants to be with his
newborn baby cuz he's a little nervous
about this whole corona thing he doesn't
want to be out walking around don't
blame him
and I don't feel like talking about
business opportunities right now
I stayed up late last night monitoring
this whole corona thing the stock market
it's scary it's a scary time I don't
know what the reality is gonna be how
it's gonna shake out but it definitely
it's not a normal day and I don't want
to talk about normal stuff today because
of that so I stayed up last night and I
came up with the list of four skill sets
that I've developed in the last 10 or 15
years maybe longer 20 years since I
started scheming since I started trying
to create businesses and I want to talk
about those today because in a way
they're kind of like I kind of think of
them as my rock my recession-proof skill
sets and these things that I'm gonna
about to I'm gonna tell you have really
changed my life and I think that if
people use them they're gonna be
impossible to stop I think that you're
gonna be able to make a living no matter
what and I'm gonna spend some time
talking about these four these four
things that I've learned throughout the
years and I'm gonna riff a little bit on
them I'm gonna tell you the resources
that I think you can turn to most of all
of them are free or they're cheap books
that you can go and acquire and read and
I think it makes a huge difference and
everything that I'm about to talk about
I've stolen from people that are smart a
lot more successful than I am that's for
sure and my perspective I think is a
little bit interesting in that we have
this event called hustle con and I've
hosted about five or six of them at this
point and throughout the years we've
probably have had I mean we could have
had 40,000 attendees throughout our
events and so we do hustle con
and we do all these other events and
because I do these events I get to have
all these really powerful and
interesting people come and speak but
about I tell everyone to show up a
little bit early so I get to spend about
an hour with them ahead of time
typically privately or with just two of
the other speakers like maybe the one
who just spoke and the one who will
speak and I'm able to ask them pretty
intimate questions because that's what I
do I I like to get the nitty gritty and
so my insight is coming from these
people and I'm talking about like folks
have started these really huge companies
or who have accomplished really
interesting or amazing things and it's
not just about money but they're
definitely successful if that's how you
want to define success but more
importantly they're successful in terms
of just turning dreams into reality and
that's really what I think that this
whole business thing is about which is
about dreams into reality how do you
take ideas and how do you shape the
world according to those ideas and it
sounds fluffy but I'm telling you this
[__] is really important and so that's
what I'm gonna talk about today some of
these are skills some of these are
mindsets mindset frameworks or whatever
you want to call it and so I'm gonna
talk about these four and I'm gonna I'm
gonna go through them relatively quickly
but I'm gonna add details and stories
where I think it's effective so let's
get into it I've got my notes here I'm
gonna be I just jotted these down in the
last few hours so we're gonna go through
them
okay the first thing that I've learned
that's been incredibly effective and
these aren't in order but this might be
the most effective which is controlling
your emotions and this sounds like some
generic advice but I'm gonna walk you
through it I we have a lot of companies
work out of our office because we got a
lot of space here and when I started my
business someone let me work out of
their office for free and so we try to
kind of do repai that that favor to
other people just getting going and I
always meet these really smart people
people who worked at McKinsey or which
is Stanford and also amazing stuff and
on paper they are perfect and they are
so smart and I always tell them the same
thing which is this is not an
intellectual game this is an emotional
game starting a business that is very
successful financially intellectually
it's very easy now maybe being like Elon
Musk and starting a company where you
sent a rocket to Mars yeah that requires
a lot of intelligence but for a lot of
companies like it could be like we work
or Institute car these things that are
Oberer these things that are really
large it's the very simple concepts and
they're not that hard to execute but
what's really hard is controlling your
emotions that's that that that's
incredibly challenging and what I've
what I've learned throughout the years
through paying a lot of money for
therapy and coaching and reading is that
the majority of both good and bad
behavior that you have now it started
back in childhood and so what I tell
people and what I've learned and when I
tell myself is if you just study your
childhood you're gonna learn a lot about
why you are reacting to certain things
and I remember being a kid I was I was
only four or five years old and this is
just an example of what of how things
that happen when you're when you're a
kid a lot of times you don't even
realize it but it actually sticks with
sticks with you I remember when I was a
kid and I was at up we were at like a
bar restaurant or something with my
family and my father was drinking it
must have been like a Jack and Coke or
something
I remember he ordered this glass and I
saw him get the straw and take it out
and I was like why are you doing that
dad I was a little kid and goes and you
just made some comment no big deal he's
like oh men don't drink with straws and
he didn't even think twice he was just
joking or I don't know he just said that
because he meant like he was saying like
men don't use like dainty straws when
they're drinking alcoholic drinks and my
whole life I never used a straw it
wasn't till I was older when I realized
oh he was first of all probably he was
just he just made some offhanded comment
even think about it and second of all he
was referring to alcohol and so for my
whole life when I went to McDonald's or
a fast food restaurant as a kid I would
never I would always pull the straw out
of the drink and that's an example of
how little things happen when you're
young and sometimes you notice some and
sometimes you don't but they entirely
shape how you behave as an adult and I
think it's very important to study your
childhood and to study how you were
raised
trauma that happened when you're young
because as you grow a company all of
those all of those things that that
happen to you they become magnified so
good things and bad things
both 10x as you get more people and as
you get a little bit more successful and
the way you react to things ways the way
you gauge risk the way that you react to
people doing what you said or them not
doing what you said the way you trust
people a lot of that stems from how you
were raised and things that happen to
you as a kid and so what I do is I I
have a therapist so I've gone to therapy
every week for maybe 10 years and I've
had to work through a lot of interesting
things but I think it's quite common
that people have the same issues that I
have but going to therapy is incredibly
important or at least it has been for me
and the other thing that I did is I have
a CEO coach that has helped a ton it's
pretty much like therapy but it's all
related to your job but like we you
really talk about all types of
relationships girlfriends wives
boyfriends husbands father mother I mean
you talk about all this stuff coworkers
and so that has been incredibly helpful
for me and so the
things that have made a massive impact
the resources at that have made that
massive impact art I used torch so torch
yo that's my that's my coach we pay him
a his name's Peter we pay my monthly fee
and myself and Adam the president of our
company go to him and it's been
wonderful the second thing is the body
keeps the score it's a great book on
dealing with trauma now
trauma a lot of times people think that
means soldiers who are in war and who
saw people die and their best friends
and they're dealing with PTSD
post-traumatic stress disorder but the
reality is is a lot of people can go
have that so whether you your parents or
your siblings or someone in your life
was abusive to you as a kid or it could
be you just got really scared you saw
something that was pretty wild it could
be when I lived in Missouri when I grew
up I remember being in fourth grade and
seeing 9/11 and it could be it's a could
be relatively small but that made a
massive difference on me and that was a
small indicator or a small example of
trauma and that shapes how you feel and
so what the body keeps the score does is
it teaches you how to recognize when
you've experienced a little bit of
trauma or a lot of bit of trauma and how
to deal with it and so that's a great
book and the second thing I like right
now is how to change your mind
I don't drink any alcohol I haven't had
a drop of alcohol in eight years
not a cent not a drop I don't do drugs
like I'm not against drugs
I'm not against weed in fact in many
regards I'm in favor of it but I
personally just don't do it because it's
never jived well with my personality
that said I'm incredibly fascinated
right now with psychedelics I have a lot
of friends who do micro dosing LSD who
do micro dosing ketamine and I'm not an
expert on it yeah but how to change your
mind is a great book that looks at
trauma and how to deal with it and how a
lot of folks are turning to psychedelics
and how that can impact you and I'm very
very interested in that and the third
thing that I really like when it comes
to controlling your emotions is this
YouTube show called
YouTube channel called School of Life
it's this philosopher named Allen I
think is Alain de Botton
I think his name is and he does a really
good job of explaining why people feel a
certain way and how to deal with that
and I have found his YouTube channel
it's free to be incredibly impactful on
controlling my emotions and the last
thing that I do this is an exercise I
thought I this was unique to me it's not
so I used to do this years ago and I
still do it to this day and it turns out
there's a name to it
it's methought exercise I call it
looking at the downside and so what I
like to do in order to control my
emotions because the thing with
controlling your emotions is you have to
control the up and the down because when
you start a company or when you start
anything typically you have a fair bit
of highs and the highs are probably as
good feeling as you as you think or
maybe even a little bit less than you
think
but the downs are typically way worse
than you can imagine it's really hard to
control the Downs because when you start
anything
controlling the down is the hard part
and most people are shocked at how low
you can feel when you're starting
something even when things appear to be
going well and so what I like to do is I
like to think in my mind I'll close my
eyes I do this a lot of times in the
morning I'll do it at night as well as I
close my eyes and I think what's the
worst possible outcome right now and so
it could be I get sick my family gets
sick
I'm gonna die and I visualize what what
that feels like and if you do it for a
long enough with your eyes closed after
about five or ten minutes you can really
feel what that feels like and then I do
two things I say to myself all right
that is the worst that can happen I just
experienced it
anything else that happens today it is
only upside and it really makes you have
a lot of gratitude and appreciate that
that hasn't actually happened and the
second thing that I like to do with this
exercise is and this relates
particularly just starting a company or
getting a job or moving somewhere else
that's new and just starting your life
is I try to protect the downside so for
example if you are gonna start a company
you can ask yourself well in order to
start this business I need a little bit
of cash and so you have to be very
specific you have to say how much cash
do I need well right now I'm spending
$3,000 a month how much how many months
saved do I need in order to feel good
about this and so let's say we come up
with the number six that means I need
six times $3,000 I need $18,000 in
savings I'm gonna go out and get that
$18,000 okay I've got that $18,000 what
else is the worst-case scenario here
what's the downside here well I spend
all my money and my business goes under
now do I want to be homeless no I'm not
willing to accept being homeless okay so
what's the net so I have to protect
myself from being homeless how would I
protect myself from being homeless well
I would probably get a job driving uber
because I have a car do I want to am I
willing to accept that
no I'm not willing to accept that or
maybe you are and then that's the
worst-case scenario but that's one stage
up could be maybe well I'll just get a
white-collar job at a huge corporation
and I'll just be a cog in their big
wheel and their machine and it won't be
fulfilling it won't be glamorous but
it'll be a really good nine-to-five with
benefits benefits so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna go and make friends with
recruiters at those companies right now
even though this isn't even coming close
to half it's not happening yet and so at
least at this point if something ever
bad happens I know that I have a
connection at IBM or I have a connection
at Target headquarters or I have a
connection at
into it or just the biggest companies in
the world and the likelihood that I can
get a job there is relatively high am I
willing to accept that that is the
worst-case scenario yes I am willing to
accept that and so what I do is I go up
the scale of like alright well where's
the lowest that I'm willing to accept
now I'm gonna lock that that that in as
best as I can
so now anything that happens above this
I am happy and it is only upside and so
that's what I like to do to control my
emotions when it comes to taking risk
the second skill that I think is
incredibly important and this is maybe
the number one or number two skill I fit
in terms of business I think it's the
number one skill and so this skill is
copywriting I think copywriting is the
most important skill that you can have
her business and one of the most
important skills that you can have in
life and here's why when you learn how
to write well you learn how to think
well you when you learn how to write
clearly you weren't learn how to think
clearly and copywriting is a particular
type of writing but it's not just
limited to writing copywriting is
understanding how people think and how
they feel and how to use the written
word or a script or spoken word in order
to sell a product or sell an idea
basically how to use words to get people
to do what you want them to do and the
way that you do that is you have to
understand what motivates them what
makes them paint what makes them work
and so this can be applied to literally
anything I have made tens of millions of
dollars this way using copywriting but
I've also met my wife this way I learned
when I was when I was trying to meet her
she was that way out of my league and so
I used what I learned in copywriting to
like get her attention and make her or
at least try to make her interested in
me
copywriting copywriting is incredibly
effective I've used it to get customers
like as in people to buy stuff from us
or for the hustle to get advertisers
I've used it to get speakers to our
events I've used it to recruit people
I've used it to sell people on this
interesting
di have copywriting is incredibly
important and it boils down to a bunch
of really simple principles but the
easiest one to remember for this
conversation is a de a I D a tension
interest desire action for the majority
of your copywriting life which for most
of you it has nothing to do with getting
a job it's just a good skill set to have
in life attention interest desire action
is the framework that you need so when
you write you line it up with attention
can I get your attention interests can I
tell you some facts that get you
interested and get you to fall down the
slippery slope because once I get you to
start reading my work I can get you to
keep buying into what I'm saying and
it's really hard to get people to fall
down that slope but interest by
specifically tell them very interesting
facts and features about the story that
you just started with your your action
point or sorry your a tension point
desires the second part so I'm gonna
make you desire whatever I'm selling and
I'm gonna get you to desire that by
telling you things that you don't know
and how this can benefit your life and
then finally action I'm gonna tell you
specifically how to get you to act and
so here's an example that my friend
Neville always uses uses that I love
which is if I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
try and convince a 15 year old guy to
drink more water I could say drink more
water it's healthy for you or and a lot
of these facts aren't necessarily true
because I didn't research what water
does for you but I very easily could use
those premise for that I'm gonna say
have you ever seen those guys with huge
muscles at the gym carrying around
gallons of water in their hand it's like
they use those milk containers to carry
water so that's how I get your attention
you see they're doing that because if
you drink if you drink a gallon of water
a day the likelihood that your muscles
will grow by 30% more than how do not
drink water now the reason that happens
and this is the desire part the yeah
this is the desire part the reason that
happens is because water has these
molecules in them that helps oxygen
travel through your blood and
oxygen is needed to build up your
muscles that's my desire part is I'm
trying to show you how to build up your
muscles and when that oxygen goes to
your muscles
they grow 30% faster so and this is the
action part if you want to build big
muscles and be healthier than before you
need to drink about a gallon of water a
day per hundred pounds of body weight so
that action part I specifically
explained how to do that now that was
just a silly example I don't none of
that shit's true but you get the point
this ADA it works wonderfully and I
always think that I always tell people
you got to learn copywriting and there's
a few great ways to learn it you can do
what I did which was very
labor-intensive and very effective but
it takes a lot of time and that's called
copy work and so what I did was I got a
hold of the hundred best sales letters
of all time I don't know what makes it
100 best but it's just famous sales
letters so and then in the 50s 60s 70s
80s and 90s before the internet really
came around and it even happened after
that but predominantly before that these
salesmen would send these letters to
people's homes and they would try to
convince people to get interested in
buying a vacuum or an encyclopedia or a
pair of sunglasses and the it was
typically the they typically wrote the
wives the the housewife would take out
her checkbook and be like oh this is
really interesting I need to buy this
and she would write a check put it into
the envelope and sale it back that's a
lot of friction and so these people were
so good at using words because it was so
expensive to send out all these letters
I had to be good they were so good at
using their words that they had to that
they convince these strangers to write a
check and mail to him and so I found
these hundred letters and if you google
best sales letters of all time you're
gonna find them and I would I spent
probably six months where I would spend
about two or three hours a day and when
I was 22 years old I would write them
all out by hand I would also do that
with books oh the Great Gatsby Saturday
Night Live live scripts I would do it
with movie scripts just any piece of
great writing I would do that with and
when you do this it's kind of like how
you learn an instrument the way that we
teach people how to play music it
incredibly effective so if I hand you a
guitar or a piano I don't say go ahead
write a song I tell you
copy the star-spangled banner' go play
jingle bells go look at Jimi Hendrix go
look at Led Zeppelin play all this all
these copy all these other people steal
their work for a little while and or
whatever genre you're interested go and
copy them exactly and in time you're
gonna learn how to feel the texture
you're gonna see the patterns that work
best that works extremely well with
writing and it's the same concept
I call it copy work this is how a lot of
people used to learn our school our
schooling the way that we do it now it's
changed over the last handful of decades
but for a long time people used to do
this Ben Franklin was a great writer and
he said this is how he learned how to
write and it's really effective so it's
called copy work the second thing that
you can do and I'm biased Neville is my
good friend but there's a guy named
Neville Medora and I actually met him
because I bought his course and I bought
his course and then after I took his
course I became friends with them and
years later we became best friends and
he was the best man at my wedding so I
love Neville and so I'm biased but his
course is what I took to learn about
copyrighting he's he's got this course
called copywriting course it's spelled
with AK a copy with a k' and course with
a k' I don't know it's always stands out
it's a great course I don't know how
much it cost right now it could cost a
few hundred bucks or a hundred I don't
even know but it's relatively affordable
and I think if you don't like it he'll
refund you his money your money but
anyway it's a great course so it teaches
a lot of this stuff it's worth it it's
totally worth it
and I actually think I used to promote
this so much that if you go to
copywriting course comm slash Sam I've
got like a referral link and I think
there's like a fifty dollar off code or
something you could use so if that
interests you do that the third thing is
this book called advertising secrets of
the written word by Jo Sugarman it's a
great book it costs $10 and I bet you if
you google google it correctly you can
find a free PDF of it online it's a
great book that walks you through
copywriting principles and why certain
things work and why they don't
and finally the last thing it's not a
copywriting thing but it's a writing
thing and it's a book by Stephen King
called on writing and the first half of
the book is it reads really fast it's
only 250 pages maybe the first half it's
all about his tools and tricks and his
toolbox he calls it his toolkit or his
toolbox for writing well and it's
incredibly effective it's it he has got
rules like don't use too many adverbs or
keep your sentences short things like
that it's incredibly effective it's a
great book on writing the second half of
the book is about his biography and it's
really really fascinating so it's called
on writing by Stephen King so the second
skill set that I wanted to go through
copywriting I think that because I know
how I would say I'm a pretty good
copywriter I'm a B because I am a B
copywriter until the day I die
I will never be homeless I will always
make money now verdicts still out if I'm
gonna be very very wealthy but I will
bet everything which I am betting
everything by starting businesses and
things like that that no matter what
happens I will always be able to make a
really good salary rather as an employee
or selling someone else's products so I
think that copywriting is incredibly
effective it's it's just it's really
useful for your life business and just
living okay we're gonna go to the third
one and the fourth one and then that's
it the third one or the third skill set
or thing that I've learned in business
that had pretty much shocked me I really
only learned this in last year but
looking back at it people have told me
this forever which is there's a massive
difference a massive gap in skills and a
lot of people cross it but there's the
gap exists of starting and managing so
when you start businesses a lot of
people think of Mark Zuckerberg and
they're like this college kid started
this thing he was 20 when he started it
now he's only 30 or he could be 25 still
and he manages 10,000 employees he hired
the best people in the world from
Princeton and Stanford and Harvard and
Seoul people from Amazon the bright
mines on earth and you think yeah that's
just how it goes well managing those
people and the business it's incredibly
challenging and oftentimes the people
who are creative and crazy enough to
start companies a lot of times the skill
sets they needed to start it are not
only different but oftentimes opposite
of what it takes to run when you start
something you could look at a lot of
spreadsheets and you could kind of like
guess your way there but a lot of times
not all the time but a lot of times
starting something it's completely
irrational on paper things may or may
not work and you just got to be creative
in you got to do [__] you got to move
fast and you're not gonna have meetings
you're not gonna talk to people about
stuff you're just gonna move quickly
you're gonna execute you're gonna do it
and it's a very creative process it's
almost like creating a piece of art like
maybe there's some equation that says
like the perfect rectangle looks this
way but every but a lot of times there's
just Picasso who just says [__] it this
is interesting to me I'm doing this and
sometimes it works that's kind of what's
starting up businesses but managing a
business is a lot different and so at
our company I did a pretty good job of
getting us to about a million a month in
sales but towards the ends of that I was
breaking I was doing horrible I was not
good at managing it and I was very
unhappy and so we hired one of my first
hires was this guy named Adam I went to
high school with and he's now president
of our company and he runs a lot of the
day-to-day stuff so I kind of I kind of
I'm like he's like Sam sandwiched in the
middle whereas I'm really good at
thinking of these really high level
ideas and I'm also really good at going
in at the very bottom and just being an
individual contributor and creating
interesting things I'm not always great
at managing the day-to-day of what's
going on it's I bet I could get good at
it but it just really doesn't interest
me and that was really hard to learn and
I struggled with this for years I like I
said I hired a CEO coach I had we have a
handful of really great angel investors
and I kind of talked to them I'm like I
don't know what to do here and it wasn't
until I realized that Adam is one of the
best at this he loves us he's the type
of guy who was the captain the football
team the president of student council
he loves leading people and it kind of
hit me I'm like man the way that I
sometimes don't understand why people
are unwilling to start something or how
on earth they're afraid of starting I am
kind of like that on the other end with
managing there's people who it whether
it comes naturally to them or they've
just worked on this skill set they're
really good at it and so in a way I was
wearing this backpack that was full of
weight and I hated carrying it on my
shoulders I just took out some of the
weight and I put it in Adams bag and he
loves carrying it and so through this
process ice mentioned earlier we have
hustle con speakers through this process
I actually talked to a lot of people at
our conferences and that was one of the
major things that I used to ask people
which is if you have a right-hand man or
a right-hand woman do you have someone
leading the day-to-day because I'm
struggling with that how do you do that
and there was typically two answers
which was yeah I don't like it it's
really hard and I could sense that these
people I'm talking I mean I don't want
to I don't want to call anyone out but
go and just Google like hasta con
speakers or something look at all the
people who we've had in our events and
those these are this is the type of
person or those are the people who told
me this which was they would say like I
am horrible at managing this or
oftentimes they would have like one of
their assistants or like a keeper or
like a handler like with them and I
would be like hey what's this person
like as a manager and if the answers
were pretty consistently pretty bad this
person is not good and so the the first
answer was I'm not good at it I'm really
struggling with it and a lot of times
those people would say I wish I had
someone who I could replace myself a CEO
I I would hear that all the time
and you I was shocked by it and the
second answer that I got was yeah I
hired a really good see oh oh or a
really good president and this is my
right-hand woman or right-hand man and
they run a lot of the day-to-day and it
allows me to focus on what I do best
and the people who said number two were
way happier and oftentimes I think a lot
more successful now there are these rare
occasions where the person who started
is just there they're there also a great
CEO or a great
people manager that that definitely
happens but often it is not the case I'm
looking at a photo of Ted Turner Ted
Turner's one of my heroes he was pretty
notoriously a bad manager he was a great
leader people wanted to follow him in
battle but what he would do is he would
come up with these great ideas so Ted
Turner came up with the idea of CNN and
he launched it but before that he had
other businesses and when he came up to
CNN a lot of people think Ted Turner
you're the guy started seeing in well
yeah he is but he also there was another
guy named Reese and Reese was the guy
leading the day-to-day Ted would come
came up with the idea and then he went
away for three months and did a sailing
competition so having these right hand
people are is very important and a lot
of times I feel like I'm the right hand
person at this point but I think that
it's really important to understand the
difference between starting and managing
I mean for a long time for a long time
it was normal that they would calm gray
hairs it was normally get a gray haired
leader to come in for a startup so these
young people would come up with this
idea for this great tech company and
then the investor would say all right
let's go guys CEO and that is not
popular right now but I think it should
be I think it's actually quite effective
maybe not CEO but you definitely need
this team of experienced people and and
so the reason why I brought this up is
it's a it's something that most people I
found struggle with but there's not a
lot of resources out there not a lot of
people talking about it and so I think
it's really important to learn this
ultimately I'm this skill set comes out
to delegating and there's four resources
that I'll have that I've liked the first
one I don't like the name of the book
but it's very helpful it's by a guy
named Fela
Felix Dennis Felix Dennis he was this
he's dead now he died a few years ago
maybe ten years ago he was he's kind of
like Richard Branson but more vulgar he
was a British entrepreneur he started
Dennis publishing which launched Maxim
magazine which launched a ton of great
titles it's still like a 200 million
dollar a year business he also launched
micro warehouse which basically before
Amazon was around it was like Amazon for
software and it was a huge multi-billion
dollar publicly-traded company so very
successful entrepreneur close to a
billionaire
and so this is why I don't mind his book
being titled so horribly it's called how
to get rich and the reason why I don't
mind it is cuz he was really successful
he wasn't this like get-rich-quick guy
and in that book he does a great job of
talking about delegating and that book I
use it as a reference book I read all
the time about how to work with people
that that's might go to the second one
is I like the one minute manager just
google it you'll find it it's a great
book on managing the third thing is [__]
is the five dysfunctions of a team and
so it's a great book that looks at what
successful teams and people look like
and what they don't look like more
importantly and so you in order to
oftentimes the best way to be good at
something is you find out the bad ways
of doing it and you just don't do that
and the fourth thing is one of my
investors is this guy named Tucker max
Tucker max if you're a man and you're
between the ages of probably 28 and 40
you probably know who Tucker max is he
was famous because you know this blog
called
I hope they serve beer in hell and it
was very controversial it was basically
about his frat days and he was just this
wild partier and drinker so he has a
really controversial opinion but after
he's in his 40s now so he's no longer a
kid but he's really thoughtful at this
point he's kind of turned his image
around and he has a great blog where he
a talked about firing himself and
replacing himself as CEO and he it's
maybe like a 12-part blog it's really
good I would highly recommend everyone
reading him and he's one of my investors
and he's kind of an a mentor to me you
know he him and I are kind of similar
and that we try to be macho and or at
least we started that way of wanting to
be macho and show no weakness but he's
actually done a really good job of being
introspective and talking about his
feelings a lot and he's done really good
about talking about managing people he
Tucker also has this great book on how
to create this great document on how to
manage a company or like create a
culture and nuclear goal Tucker max
culture document and you'll see it it's
free okay the fourth and final skill set
that I want people to take away from
this rambling is how to influence people
in fluent whether you I'll collect
persuasion or influence it's really
similar to similar to copywriting but
this one's a little bit more
psychological but it's similar and what
most people don't realize is how to get
people to do what you want them to do or
how to influence them to think how you
think and that sounds evil but that's
not how I mean it I mean you could use
it for evil ways I mean the stuff that
you convince people to give to a
non-profit or you convince people of
certain morals or why something's bad
and something's good it's the same stuff
that you can use to get people to do a
lot of really bad things and so this is
definitely a scary skill set to learn
but if you but the thing is is that
people are like animals I mean in the
same way that if you show a dog food
you know what's that Pavle Pavlovian
experiment where you you show dog food
and you ring a bell so the dog starts
associating the bell with the food and
so whenever you ring the bell he starts
slobbering people are the same way you
can there's all these little tricks that
you can do to get people to say yes to
certain things or get them to buy into
certain things more so for example if
I'm a politician and I want to put a
huge billboard in your front yard the
likelihood that I of me just knocking on
your door and asking to put this big
billboard in yards in your yard the
likelihood of you saying yes is pretty
low but if I go in there and I say hey
can I put this small little sticker on
your window and you and they're likely
gonna be saying yes so that is quite
high now if I go back a week later and
ask you to put this big billboard in
your front yard the likelihood then that
you're gonna say yes is a lot higher
than had I not asked you to put that
small sticker because you're already
bought in and there's about eight or
nine principles just like this of
getting you to buy anything so another
one's the rule reciprocity and so what
that means is let's say that I I go out
or let's say that you go out of town and
you and I'm your neighbor and you ask me
to check your mail for you when I'm gone
and I say yeah sure no problem I'll
check your mail you I've just done a
favor for you now you owe me a favor and
this is how humans work we all we work
on favors and so now let's say next week
I go hey look I wash I I checked your
mail last week can I borrow you
car for a day the likelihood that you're
gonna say yes is actually a lot higher
because I've already done you a favor
and so the interesting thing about the
rural reciprocity is that people pay it
back disproportionately meaning I can do
a really small favor for someone and
then I can ask them to do a much bigger
favor and shockingly so a lot of times
they'll say yes and so there's about
eight or nine of these principles that
are incredibly effective for influencing
people another example I've used this
before I wanted to go I went and bought
a motorcycle for a guy for three grand
or he was asking three grand for and I
thought it was I thought yeah I'd be
willing to pay about 2,200 bucks for
this and so I went and bought a can of
coke I bought two of them and when I
showed up to the place I opened up one I
start drinking I go hey man you thirsty
they you want a coke I was just down the
street and I bought one and I thought
maybe you'd want one too he opened it up
he starts drinking it and I go cool
motorcycle I'll give you twenty two he
goes huh everyone's been offering me
that I'm not gonna do it but you seem
like a nice guy I'll do it fine and so I
don't know if the coke was the reason
but that's just an example of there's
all these little tiny things that if you
do them effectively they kind of add up
to be pretty effective and so to learn
these things there's this great book by
Robert Chow Dini called influence maybe
just google influence book you'll see it
seems Robert Chow Dini
read that it's it's that book changed my
life and the second one which is pretty
famous a lot of people know it's called
how to win friends and influence people
that book I think that book is one of
the best-selling books of all time the
best-selling non-fiction books of all
time it was written in the 1930s 1920s
it's still 100 percent effective so go
and read those two books and I and I
think that if you learn how to influence
people it's really really really
effective and it will shock you now like
I was a nerd in high school and I liked
women and so it was always just like any
other kid I wanted to go meet girls I
remember reading this book as a kid I
was like I want them to like me how do I
do that
and so I read this book and I
would apply this stuff to meet girls and
it worked I am married to a an amazing
woman and she was way out of my league
when I first met her and she still is
out of my league and I remember I use
some of these things when I met her and
it helped me kind of get my foot in the
door it's so this stuff will help you
make money and will help you start a
company it'll help you balance your
emotions or it will help you meet your
your future spouse it's incredibly
effective and so I'm gonna wrap this up
those are the four skills that I wanted
to talk about today this whole corona
thing man it's it's weird and didn't I
didn't want to talk about little
business and schemes today but I wanted
to talk about a few things that actually
impact your life more than just more
foundational things that can impact your
life bigger than just a business and I
don't know maybe maybe we'll have to
call this like the there were recession
proof skill set or something like that
but that's it let me know how you feel
about this I miss my best bud Sean my
co-host these aren't here today but
maybe we'll try to publish this the same
day that I've recorded it what's today
today Wednesday I don't even know it's
Thursday today's Thursday it's 11:00
a.m. so tweet at me the same power let
me know what you thought about this have
you actually made it all the way through
maybe we'll do more of them but uh good
luck talk to you soon
[Music]
you